françois de rugy ce week-end dans la
région de france à l'initiative de son
président xavier bertrand une grande
manifestation de nettoyage du territoire
qualifié haute france propre a connu un
réel succès rassemblant 50 mille de nos
concitoyens sur toute la région
cette manifestation volontaire solidaire
et écologique a malheureusement été
entaché par une police ou par une
pollution d'origine maritime survenue
quelques jours auparavant sur le
littoral du nord du pas de calais ainsi
que de la somme cette pollution a été
minimisée dans les mois à la suite de
l'événement au large des côtes de
charente maritime était fort dramatique
et inquiétant la paraffine qui est en
cause provoque ce désordre régulièrement
sur nos plages
deux à trois fois par an depuis déjà
plusieurs années ceci est d'huile nous
le savons tous au nettoyage au nettoyage
des cuves 2 chimiquiers madame la
ministre
la semaine dernière le gouvernement fut
interpellé au sujet du grande des
américains
à cette occasion il a été déclaré que
des propositions seraient faites au
niveau européen pour renforcer la
sécurité la réglementation il y a donc
urgence quel recours technique et
judiciaire
comptez vous engager afin de pénaliser
les contrevenants au maintien de la
biodiversité de l'un des détroits les
plus fréquentés du monde
et surtout notre littoral merci pour
vous répondre
l'apparent les et la secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre d'état lida
transition écologique et solidaire à la
barre dont vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
le sénat les sénateurs monsieur
sénateurs à pain vous avez raison de
nous alerter sur cet épisode de
pollution à la paraffine qui a touché
les côtes picarde
effectivement nous avons été alertés le
lundi 18 mars sur l'existence de
dizaines de boulettes de paraffine qui
ont touché les côtes depuis fort mahon
dans la somme jusqu'à marck en calaisis
dans le pas de calais et ses
associations ce mot se sont mobilisés
dès le week end du 16 et du 17 mars pour
nettoyer les plages
je voudrais d'ailleurs salué la
mobilisation des associations des
communes et des citoyens sachant que
environ 200 litres de paraffine ont pu
être récupérés dans cette opération de
nettoyage
l'état s'est immédiatement mobilisé bien
sûr les directions départementales des
territoires et de la mer de la somme et
du pas de calais
ont effectué des prélèvements effet les
analyses toxicologiques de ces
prélèvements qui sont rassurantes
pas de risque particulier pas de danger
d'intoxication les préfectures ont par
ailleurs repassé les consignes de
protection habituelle
attention à ne pas manipuler lorsqu on
nettoie les plages la paraffine à mains
nues il faut des gants des lunettes et
des équipements de protection pour
toutes les consignes de sécurité
mais la question que vous posez c'est la
question des causes et notre capacité à
agir des causes vous l'avez dit sont
connus ce sont des navires qui
lorsqu'ils circulent dans les couloirs
de navigation effectué des rejets au
moment des nettoyages de fond de cuve
serre ges sont dans certains cas
autorisés à l'heure actuelle par
l'organisation maritime internationale
bien sûr avec des plafonds et sous
certaines conditions
cette situation n'est pas satisfaisante
dès lors deux actions sont engagés
d'abord une enquête en cours de la
direction des affaires maritimes pour
déterminer la cause et bien sûr engager
les poursuites si le navire en question
est identifié et ensuite plus
globalement avec le centre de lutte
contre la pollution maritime nous nous
mobiliserons pour porter ce sujet au
plan communautaire comme au plan
international monsieur rapin merci
madame la ministre mais je pense qu'il
faut pénaliser beaucoup plus fort ces
actions et je vais vous soumettre une
idée finalement puisque il semble qu'on
ait dit des difficultés à financer la
résilience et la protection du trait de
côte il serait un terrain intéressant de
prendre une partie de la pénalisation et
des financements et des financements
liés à la pénalisation pour pour assurer
ce problème de la de la résilience donc
madame la ministre il faut agir il faut
agir et vite
merci d'abord